good morning John it's Friday June 20th
and I have a mohawk a big fake mohawk
and I have some and my eyes are burning
what the hell it's like hair paint mixed
with mace it's pretty green huh okay now
for real punishment complete I dressed
up like a freakin goth and then I
spray-painted a fauxhawk green none of
my punishment is complete on more
important business the most important
business for the day I think has to do
the fact that my chair will in fact spin
on its own at a certain speed as long as
I am sitting on it now I think that
maybe I might have discovered some kind
of perpetual motion machine and I should
probably be seeking some kind of patent
what is this like the weight of my body
on my chair makes it spin okay actually
the most important piece of business for
the day is that people liked my Harry
Potter song a lot the truth of the
matter is that I like it a lot too I
actually find myself singing it quite a
lot which feels kind of funny I also
sometimes sing it in different styles
I'm getting kinda tired of this brain
publication media blitz okay they got
all of muggle can under their spell
don't they know the whole was already
gone and reserved to copy at Amazon Oh
many more books to they expect to sell
just give me my book or go to hell just
in general ah yeah I like some kind face
well I can't take all the credit
Katherine helped me write it we sat on
the porch and I played and I'd be like
God nothing in the world rhymes with
Belle kathan be like um spell is a good
word for a song about Harry Potter and
I'd be like
yeah spell so a bit of a group effort
also Lizzie from the leaky cauldron who
helped to spread the word about the
video and everyone who read in the video
hi
that's amazing everyone who favorited it
that's also amazing I right now have the
number 5 top rated song on YouTube which
is kind of like a dream come true I have
a small understanding of what it would
be like to be a small-time rock star
that is how I'm feeling right now which
is sort of an amazing feeling but it
could be better so please everyone do
what you will with the song it's only
kind of good until tomorrow when the
book comes out so you know it'd probably
be good to get as many people listening
to it as possible in the next 12 hours
please do what you can to avoid spoilers
they've been popping up all over the
place and we're doing our best to
prevent them from being anywhere near
Brotherhood 2.0 but we can't watch
everything all at once so just close
your eyes as fast as you can whenever
you see anything about Harry Potter I
put a link to an mp3 of the file below
right there if you're on Brotherhood to
calm otherwise you can go to brother
Futuna calm and it will be there I am
really glad that everyone liked it so
much it's really good to have people
saying such nice things they may change
their mind not they see my green mohawk
but nonetheless um thank you all very
much by this time tomorrow those of us
who care will have copies of Deathly
Hallows and I won't expect to be hearing
from any of you but John I will see you
on Monday